mi chiama io il mio tipo Mica lo
condivido Ma ti pare a parte che quello
che gli do io quella non glielo dà Oh un
attimo non lo vedete che sto parlando
Minchia sono solo una io voi siete a 60
in coda Io sono una incazza ciao Pablo
lavoro ha la tessera la vuole fare No
vabbè Peggio per lei non poteva
usufruire di €1 di sconto all'anno vedi
la gente ricca non si vede che se lo
vuoi permettere signora se lo interessa
acquistando sei già igienizzanti da 667
mm ne avrà uno omaggio non ne vuole Oh
per me non c'è nessun problema Minchia è
lei che andrà in giro piena di germi
posso proporre questo bagnoschiuma al
mentono che si rito lo a €3 neanche
questo Oh Ci mancherebbe Ah minchia
avete la gente che non si lava più ricca
Insomma sono le leggi Oh signora si è
dimenticata Questo è un buono da €2 da
spendere la terza domenica di un mese
estivo di un anno bisestile siete sicuri